there's a video that was going viral
this was Emily radakowski who truly I
could not pick her out of a lineup I
just saw this lady going I thought she
was a random lady just like a random
private citizens go viral these days
turns out she's Emily radakowski who's a
big model or something and she was
encouraging women to get divorced
so it seems that a lot of ladies are
getting divorced
before they turn dirty and as someone
who got married at 26 has been separated
for a little over a year
32 I have to tell you
I don't think there's anything better if
being in your 20s is the trenches there
is nothing better than being in your 30s
still being hot maybe having a little
bit of your own money figuring out what
you want to do with your life everything
and having tried that married fantasy
and realizing that it's maybe not all
it's cracked up to be and then you've
got your whole life still ahead of you
um so for all of those people who are
stressed or feeling stressed about that
about being divorced like it's a it's
it's good congratulations
congratulations
congratulations the lady doth protests a
little too much me thinks really
terrible advice divorce is always just
awful in all circumstances it's terrible
and
it's a fallen world and it happens
sometimes and the culture used to
greatly discourage it now the culture
encourages it the law encourages it
through things like no fault divorce and
through the abolition of the meaning of
marriage by by redefinition and judicial
Fiat thanks to the Romantic poet Justice
Anthony Kennedy so everything is and the
whole culture of hyper individualism uh
is is aimed at destroying the family
which is destroying the country and it's
making everybody miserable you you know
I don't cite social scientific
statistics and because I think they're
bogus but when they support My Views I'm
happy to cite them
people have gotten much more miserable
you see this in self-reported rates of
happiness you see this especially in the
reports of rates of happiness for women
you see this in the prescriptions of
depression pills which have skyrocketed
for everybody but especially for women
you see this in uh the the average life
expectancy in the United States which
has declined because of deaths of
Despair you see this in the major drug
epidemic and the suicide epidemic for uh
white men in their middle age in
particular
people are really miserable and this is
coincided exactly with the sexual
Revolution at the center of which is
divorce divorce it's just and so we we
try to prune around the edges of the
sexual Revolution with this you know
fashionable ideology that YouTube won't
let me talk about or with the
redefinition of marriage or with the
lgbtq movement but it really comes down
to divorce and it's a political problem
not just a personal problem because it's
the fundamental political unit it's the
Bedrock unit of multiple people forming
a cohesive body on which you build
townships and counties and states and
ultimately a nation so one it's a it's a
political matter it's public you're
speaking to people you take a vow in
front of the public in front of a in
front of a minister in front of God and
we have the right to say something about
that because Emily radakowski's
selfishness or it just you know extreme
fatal supply of copium is uh not just a
problem for her it's a problem for the
whole country threatens the very social
fabric now before we go speaking of
women
I I do have to get to the story because
I teased it and it's not a long story to
get to it'll eat into mailbag a little
bit but we have to get to it Joe Biden
is very very old
and now
CBS News has asked the awkward question
to his Vice President are you ready
so you're 58 now if you win the second
term as you and the president are
running to do he would be 86 at the end
of it The Wall Street Journal had a poll
showing two-thirds of Democrats say Joe
Biden is too old to run again
[Music]
are you prepared to be
commander-in-chief yes I am if necessary
but Joe Biden is going to be fine and
let me tell you something
a little quick on the draw there are
common left not a great look first of
all she's obviously not ready to be
president though the government can
effectively operate without a president
now as it has been under under Biden so
I guess
she's as ready as anybody in that the
role of the individual in the office of
president has been diminished
but not a good look for Kamala
because in this case you're supposed to
say listen
Joe Biden is totally ready to go
uh there is no fear whatsoever that he's
going to drop dead or drop out of the
race or anything
so it's obviously when I accepted the
role of Vice President a prerequisite
for that is that one is prepared to step
into the role God forbid but I I'm not
but you see that question are you ready
yes okay what what did you did you just
get a phone call did something happen I
mean um no Biden he's really good so
people champing at the bit to take over
for Old Joe in the election
even the Democratic primary that
election could get even more Bonkers
than it already is right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles is your cell phone
in desperate need of replacement you
know the signs short battery life so you
have to have a charger on hand cracked
screen that gives you glass splinters
it's time to put that old phone to rest
and upgrade to a 5G brand new Samsung
Galaxy from Pure Talk for free get a
free 5G Samsung Galaxy with two day
battery life edge to edge display and
Ultra strong Gorilla Glass when you sign
up for Pure talks unlimited talk text
and 15 gig data plan for just 35 bucks a
month plus it comes with a mobile
hotspot if you are not using pure talk
you are simply paying too much get all
the data you could ever need for half
the price of the big carriers on
America's Most Dependable 5G Network
right now head on over to puretalk.com
Knowles for your free super durable 5G
Samsung Galaxy when you switch to Pure
Talk use the cell service that I love
and trust and use myself that is
puretalk.com
make the switch to Pure Talk the
official Wireless partner of the daily
wire
Mike Huckabee just got into a hot water
oh boy all the left-wing opposition
groups they were sending this clip
around this was on Governor Huckabee's
excellent show Huckabee
on which he said that if the legal
shenanigans that the Liberals are trying
right now to keep Trump off the ballot
if they stop Trump from winning the
election then this will be the last
election decided by ballots rather than
bullets
do you know how political opponents to
those in power are dealt with in third
world dictatorships banana republics and
communist regimes well it's simple the
people in power use their police
agencies to arrest their opponents for
made-up crimes in an attempt to
discredit them bankrupt them imprison
them Exile them are all of the above
and if you're not paying attention you
may not realize that Joe Biden is using
exactly those tactics to make sure that
Donald Trump is not his opponent in
2024. here's the problem if these
tactics end up working to keep Trump
from winning or even running in 2024 it
is going to be the last American
election that will be decided by ballots
rather than bullets
there it is it's he's threatening he's
another insurrectionist we got to throw
Mike Huckabee in prison for 20 years
Mike Huckabee said nothing wrong every
single thing Mike Huckabee just said Is
Right
regardless of even what happens in the
election and how you interpret it
if
the legal mechanisms that the Liberals
are trying to use which are really
illegal mechanisms if they succeed at
taking Trump off the ballot in certain
places then the likelihood of civil war
is much higher the last time that we had
a president elected not being on the
ballot in a number of states was
immediately before the Civil War that's
just an historical fact
he's not saying if Trump loses the
election fair and square then the next
election is going to be decided by
bullets rather than ballots he's saying
if these
unfair often illegal operations that the
Liberals are trying if those succeed
then you're gonna have a breakdown of
the Electoral order that's obviously
true it's it's even true
if the the Liberals exert this kind of
power and keep the conservative from
having a fair shake at being elected
even then even if the conservatives do
nothing
and they sit at home on their hands it
will nevertheless remain true that the
future elections will be decided by
bullets rather than ballots because the
the bullets will be in the guns pointed
by the state at the people who want to
challenge the regime if there is no
longer to be any real political
opposition permitted in the United
States if every time an actual
opposition leader tries to run he gets
shut down because the the Liberals won't
even let him be placed on the ballot
then that means that our elections are
decided by bullets rather than ballots
because they're they're decided by the
implicit coercive force of the state of
the regime ABS as is often the case with
Mike Huckabee what he's saying is
obviously obviously true boy what a
great clip that was now make sure that
you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel we'll
see you next time